le volontariat sauve des vies il
accompagne et protège au quotidien des
millions d'Européens je veux ici saluer
le dévouement de ces femmes et ses
hommes qui veillent sur notre société
renforcent le lien social et la
solidarité je pense plus
particulièrement où sapeurs-pompiers à
la protection civile et bien sûr à tous
les volontaires en Europe ces
engagements sont nécessaires pour
apporter les premiers secours mais aussi
et cela prend une place toujours plus
importante aujourd'hui pour faire face
aux changements climatique pourtant les
interprétations de la directive sur
l'aménagement du temps de travail
fragilise le statut de ces volontaires
et singulièrement des pompiers
Monsieur le Commissaire excusez-moi je
salue à ce titre l'engagement de
plusieurs de mes collègues plus
particulièrement Sylvie Brunet qui
travaille pour une meilleure
reconnaissance de leur statut au
Parlement afin d'améliorer la prévention
partout en Europe nous devons favoriser
les échanges entre volontaires ou de la
des frontières ainsi que leur formation
dans le cadre du mécanisme européen de
protection civile et du Corps européen
de solidarité par exemple ensemble
rendons à ces volontaires les égards de
leur dévouement sans faille pour notre
sécurité